newly released video contradicts initial  counts of a deadly firefight between a  Jordanian soldier and three American  Green Berets their surveillance video  shows a u.s. convoy approaching a  Jordanian base last November when a  guard opens fire two Green Berets leave  their trucks take cover and return the  fire the shooting was initially  described as a split second mistake by  the Jordanian but the video shows the  Green Berets waved their hands and tried  to surrender Jordanian kept firing staff  sergeants Mathew Llewellyn Kevin McEnroe  and James Moriarty were killed  Jordanian court last week sent us the  guard to light imprison